ciao a tutti no non è il cibo non è si
fa allora ordinato su happy una mistery
box di sliven e prima cosa che conclude
in questo caso sono misteriose allora io
milano ad essere box mi è arrivata una
bi tri band perché una mano in una casa
lo status peloso che la direttamente dal
regno unito quindi lui deve essere di
estrema dentro siano intoppi o se sia un
disastro speriamo solo che comunque sono
fessi strain ma anche voi potrete dirsi
se approvate o ferioli approvate due
rigori parati remo corni lasciato in
bellezza questo video e se volete vedere
anche unboxing oltre comprati non so
ditemi voi
iniziamo subito senza guardare
non ci credo sarroch dio che cosa è
successo qua nemmeno si apre non si era
così e proprio brunch e lato non
rispetti la birra butta oh mio dio no
magari dello slam di a lui non ci ha
sorpreso soprattutto possibile che con
era ridotto consigli
oh mio dio non c'è niente di salvabile
qua
guardale novo per vedere cosa ci fosse
scritto qua dentro è terribile
sì bagnato praticamente a parte che se
ne allora ci sono 3 3 ma bastano uno sia
aperto nonostante ci fosse lo scotch
tutto intorno cioè non so neanche da
dove è uscito fuori chiuso senza aver
rotto la partitina furto la cosa
positiva è che profumato
aspettiamo che le paste di sfracellato
vediamo se 100 di salvabile
anche perché c'è uno stile mette di
fronte sugli altri slime praticando
mangiateli a dover mangiare qualcosa dai
programmi capire più nessuno robusto
diego mi fiderei guarda io comunque a mi
sono dimenticato di dire che questa
mistery box ha solamente 10 euro quindi
comunque il prezzo era molto basso però
appunto mi dispiace che si sia braccia
il lotto così allora vediamo prima gli
extra per casiraghi fuori allora qua
stranamente black sabbath mai fatto
fresco il 5 si sono sempre allora questi
sono degli stickers con gli smile est di
baghdad
imation mai nel reich spighe tutte le
varie mozione come
addensare lo slime allora falsi del
boras quindi fa piacere che ha messo
qualcosa in più qua c'è personale che si
cassano tipo per per legare i cavi
veramente a ok puoi mettere a 0 con più
di questi di solito si compra un
pacchetto di questi personaggi le cui
annotare mano con mano ferma per fare
dico una specie di grande elastico che è
molto divertente quasi un must ma a una
conti
a parte che tutto sciolto no io ti
proibisco quindi non ci pare che
qualcosa te la stai dentro poi e totti
co no non lo mangi non proviamo angelo
cosa poi un altro extra sempre ricco
porzione di sliven sono degli stick
solini scuole smettila non puoi mai
balle
allora vediamo agli slum di per se
vediamo se tra l'altro tutto il tavolo
si è sporcato anche va beh vediamo
innanzitutto questo strano allora
iniziamo da questo primo slime che è
quello incriminato
[Musica]
penso che sia sceltissimo per quello che
è tutto uscito fuori si è sciolto qua io
terribile va aggiunta al fido borico
attivatore che mi sa che non ce l'ho in
questo momento
andiamo abbiamo pochissimo che fanno g
crescita allora il gruppo di attivatore
spero che solo questo sia sciolto perché
me ne è rimasto pochissimo
spero che passi l'ho ordinato ma oddio
ma è proprio il liquido ma non so
nemmeno se lo abbia attivato questa
persona perché è veramente liquido
sembra che insieme è stato attivato
questo spline boh non capisco però
[Musica]
provato a sentire un po di bicarbonato
manovra un niente sto provando a
riattivarlo ma si sembra veramente che
non sia mai stato attivato da quanto è
liquido ok forse si sta riuscendo
piano piano si sta attivando sempre meno
pescoso però si ha una consistenza
abbastanza rigida mi piacciono queste
palline che fanno davies suoni oggi
cos'è questa cosa
oddio che cos'è e cosa di sporcizia
lo vedi non so se riuscito a vederlo se
tipo un pelo un coso sporco nero ok
allora non lo voglio più toccare questo
slime questo slime mi è piaciuto per
niente non so se sia colpa del viaggio
come è stato fatto ma
non sono per niente contento con questo
slime di vediamo ai prossimi
allora guardiamo notarmi giallo speriamo
che questo sia liquido latte o le mani
impiastricciate oddio liquidi stimo che
questo però volle sul buon odore almeno
mano stadi col boss non so se mi basta
l'attivatore per attivarlo proviamo
allora ragazzi sono riuscito a
recuperare un pezzo è questo è lo slime
non so se per colpa mia forse perché
sono andata nuovamente ad attivarlo però
si è indurito un po troppo vedete forse
sono io che ho aggiunto troppo
attivatore super liquido ma altrimenti
non si attivava proprio comunque non mi
piace per niente questo slime perché
guardate un po
inutile inutilizzabile proprio sono si
sono rimasta abbastanza male ma ripeto
non so a parte che perde tutte le
palline
non so se questo caso è colpa mia
per ora veramente di quello vero
impossibile giocarci senza alti parlo
troppo però minimi di spese che su tre
slime due inutili proprio su questo qua
e liquido non si può proprio salvare
qualifica al kg sul tavolo va beh questo
è l'ultima speranza notare le mie mani
come sono messe bene comunque questa è
la mia ultima speranza vediamo un po
ok anche questo e liquidi simo sembra
con la praticamente sembrato la prova
aggiungere qualcosa ma non ho uno
stimatore troppo liberamente su che
cos'è questa cosa nera
oddio basta un pezzo di sporcizia tipo
mamma mia che schifo
se veramente ci superò prezzi di
sporcizia in questo slime ma come si fa
c'è chi mette slam si deve lavare le
mani prima di fare design
insomma sono veramente rimasta male
questi sono dei terzini veramente uno
schifo cioè guardate il sociale della
mistery box unica cosa che posso salvare
è l'asino polico qua questi gesti che
tra quei questi sporchi ma per fortuna
questa massa top 10 euro però c'erano
anche dieci auto di spedizione quindi
alla fine ho speso 20 o 21 euro per
questo sciolto che fosse sciolto magari
non è colpa della persona che lo ha
fatto perché magari era il rialzo non lo
so
anche se non fa tantissimo caldo del
però il fatto che si è sporco è
veramente terribile terribile non è
giustificabile
anche perché se vendi il tema delle
persone devi lavarti le mani comunque
prima di fare lo slalom conclusa gli
ingredienti puliti non puoi vedere il
fianco della sporcizia dentro le basi la
sporcizia all'interno lascia un
pochettino ad essere fare il punto ci
può stare comunque mancando nei depositi
magari ci sia fatto tanto caldo si
scioglie passato stava poco perché
perché la verità un po bassina però è
inutile c'è anche se una cosa costa poco
e poi arriva così è proprio inutile
perché stai comunque e buttandosi poi
non sei contento cioè non è contento di
riconferma
io ci sono rimasta veramente male
nessuno srive probabile speravo di
vedere degli spline insomma diversi
belli mi potevo fare del po king dei
suoni
invece purtroppo sacco ci vedo l'ora di
lavare le mani si sa mai quello che si
riceve soprattutto nella mente dei box
niente io purtroppo non posso dirvi
altro perché non vi posso far vedere
perché bene questo è il tutto e niente
però ripeto non so di chi sia l'apporto
a voi nei commenti cosa ne pensate di
questa cosa mi è successo anche voi
avete mancato del jazz live verranno
ridotti malissimo e utilizzabili per me
la prima volta che riscontro quindi non
so se succede spesso questa cosa
comunque niente farsi sempre tutto nei
commenti ora vi lasciamo con quattro
catherine si può cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video e non si estende le
nostre salentina scrivete divertenti
cliccate su quella che prix fie e buona
visione
ciao